[Music]
let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
fall in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
foreign
[Applause]
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
I'll fly away together
into the forever
[Music]
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
we're noticed how black your eyes were
they were replaced by my father as a
method of torture he he picked a pretty
set